[Music]
so i know you covered this mic
on nightway if you you you told me you
covered
this so first off i apologize people
might be hearing this again but i i
didn't i must have completely missed
nobody watches night wave it's fine
i must have completely missed it no no
what do you what do you think night wave
is for the sunday night show people
watch it um
ouch yeah
that hurt that hurt my feelings and i
wouldn't be caught dead on that show
i wouldn't either but that's because i
don't get invited yeah me neither okay
um
so uh
everyone like the more we pick on frozen
the more people start to like him and i
really don't like this it's making it
worse i'm gonna just be nice to him
um
black rifle coffee apparently a couple
weeks ago
decided that he was going to uh well why
don't we just play something okay
sure
i know this is a long clip
but uh who are these guys michael if you
want to skip to the well i mean you
could play some of this um because it's
fine but like
once it starts to drag on a little bit i
think you could go up ahead to like i
think i know where the alex thing is
like almost halfway through okay if not
i have the alex clip isolated anyway
all right so uh their black rifle coffee
has been doing everything they can all
right
and look i know what you're thinking
you're looking at these guys and like
they're cool they have tito's on the
[ __ ] table
yeah they're cool bro they drink they
got the o.j simpson jersey in the
background which is super edgy and cool
his wife and his boyfriend yeah uh
they're all everyone on this show
is a confirmed murderer themselves uh
every one of them has been in the
military uh every one of them
uh probably has some pretty cool
confirmed kills
these are tier one operators bro don't
[ __ ] around with them so uh i haven't
unlocked them yet and uh i
didn't buy the battle pass this year in
call of duty
just using the regular yeah i'm using
the ones that come with the game
i'm not gonna pay extra it's just
cosmetic anyway yeah i i didn't i didn't
see the guy on the left see if you
unlocked the douchebag skin oh it's a
douchebag yeah but it's not you can't
buy it in the store it's one of those if
you pre-ordered i got it got it i got it
uh
and the one on the right looks like he
drove chris cuomo to the club
he really does so these are the looks
like his he looks like his security
detail he's on vacation so these are the
black rifle guys right black rifle
apparently got into some [ __ ] because
they were talking [ __ ] about you know he
doesn't want any racist to be to buy his
coffee and [ __ ] like that i don't know
whatever yeah no we we market we market
our coffee to people who uh make thirty
thousand dollars a year fighting israel
and saudi arabia's wars and murdering
children that [ __ ] is badass like boom
bang air strikes hitting [ __ ]
villages killing all kinds of people
right that shit's cool
but i don't want to hear like racist
jokes around me bro i don't play that
[ __ ]
so what happened with black rifle coffee
is they started getting pigeonholed to
be in the conservative coffee thing and
i think they wanted to start marketing
to they wanted to be the dude bro coffee
they didn't get pigeonholed
they marketed themselves
themselves they made themselves that so
that they had a starting off customer
base and then once they could elevate
the grift and cut those people out there
like every other business in the world
they always end up selling everybody out
so the both of these guys are started it
right just so i kept we have the
background i think so the guy on the
right definitely was one of the founders
and i think the guy on the left or one
of the other guys on the show was one of
the co-founders at one point and then
it's like you know black rifles always
sponsored the show obviously okay well
let's check it out
we number one we have nothing to hide
number two it was like we had this
adaptive athlete shoot that evan
designed that he's so excited about he's
like well [ __ ] come talk about this like
that we are bringing out all these
amputees that have now gotten into yeah
so it was like hey hey what about all
the people that are amputees when you
were blowing off their limbs in the
middle east
that's our thought problem that was bad
ass though because they're brown
process wasn't essentially like yeah the
new new york times sucks like which yeah
their business model is
controversy and sinking [ __ ] ships
that they can sink and isn't that what
you did in the military
yeah for real but but really doing it i
i don't want you to fetishize the
military industrial complex and then use
analogies like yeah sinking ships
controversy whoa let's not
let's calm down i'll call the new york
times right now we'll get you right back
on that list
yeah and getting people to [ __ ] fight
and and the the the statements that a
lot of people are mad about evan was
making uh from a direct
question that was what do you think
about the people you lost as customers
after
back in november when the whole kyle
written house thing hit and
man from our person yes we covered the
kyle ryan house thing they wouldn't back
out red house even though he was clearly
defending himself
uh
and people got mad
because they weren't you know they
weren't backing a guy who again actually
watched the video was clearly defending
himself
yeah the one thing i will say is they
shouldn't have
the way they handled that was poor
but
i would have been pissed if i was them
too
only in that like that [ __ ] what's
his name remember that lynn wood that
scumbag lawyer who like is crazy now
he was the one that gave written house
the black rifle coffee shirt to where
right and tried to like
oh i guess i i agree with you you know
what i mean but it's but the the reason
black rifle sucks is
all they had to do was go
hey look you know uh we know the story
of kyle written house um you know
recently he was seen wearing one of our
shirts we just want to say we haven't
donated or anything
but like they didn't just say hey yeah
we didn't donate or anything but you
know we wish him luck or whatever they
just tripled down and they're like yeah
he's a racist murderer like anything to
do with that you're like whoa what like
all right you could have just said hey i
don't know where you got that shirt but
we're not sponsoring that you know what
i mean but they didn't yeah they
whatever everybody everybody in this
right-wing griff [ __ ] sucks using
that perspective
we faced crazy attacks from proud boy
factions they were incredibly racist and
anti-semitic i mean we've got plenty of
screenshots and videos and they're all
proud boys by the way
if anyone who writes me a letter yelling
at me as a proud boy merch and i aren't
[ __ ] proud boys and [ __ ] we make fun
of the proud boys this morning we have
ripped on the proud boys worse than you
ever will drink in bros and you know
what we get we get messages all the time
from proud boys being like
yeah man it's fine we we get it we have
senses of humor
but the problem with that with with this
this whole thing
is that they do the same thing that the
[ __ ] liptards do man which is they go
anybody that disagrees with what we're
saying has to be a racist or a homophobe
now in merchandise case yes that's true
but in other people's cases it's not
coordinated attacks going in on telegram
and all this [ __ ] like signal telegram
yes there was there was this giant and
before that i want i want to also paint
the picture prior to oh by the way when
i covered this on night wave i put out a
thousand dollar bounty
uh to all of these drinking bros guys if
they could give me
the name
of one proud boy that sent them
threatening
racist
emails
sure i was like i will give you
one thousand dollars cash to black rifle
if you guys can come up with
one proof that proof of one actual proud
boy because here's what happened they
said in the interview those racist proud
boy types then when they got attacked
they just assumed it was all proud boys
it wasn't it was 4chan people it was
twitter it was people organizing on
telegram
none of them were proud like
these are just like these guys are
learning now
that this is how the internet works
half of the people that probably wrote
them a bunch of threatening like racist
misogynistic was probably they probably
had no ideological bent yep they
probably didn't even have a s they were
probably just [ __ ] posters that are like
oh wow look at the tough war veterans
who can't even like look at them [ __ ]
look at these snowflakes look at them
[ __ ] spiraling so people are like you
know what i'm going to write them an
email [ __ ] with them this is hilarious
like you don't understand there are more
people on the internet that are rooting
for chaos that are rooting for the right
or the left there's a lot of people that
will jump on this and go oh i didn't
know they were that sensitive all right
let's [ __ ] with them
i'm just [ __ ] really [ __ ] i'll tell
you this
i
i'm really really mad at these [ __ ]
noncoms that that come and they [ __ ]
griff their coffee like they're [ __ ]
soldiers they use their military service
as you can i was the military what did
you die for not israel i could [ __ ]
tell you that and and and the whole like
oh anti-semitic remarks you're right
probably to get anti-semitic remarks but
i'm [ __ ] sure i'll put [ __ ] money
on this i will put [ __ ] money on it
that when they were in the military and
they were they were calling them hajis
and [ __ ]
words and all that stuff do you think
that they weren't being [ __ ] racist
to them get the [ __ ] out of here
get the [ __ ] out of here one of my
favorites was um
was the um
what do you call it the scene in uh
generation kill
when like fruity rudy because he's like
all hippy buddhist guy and he's like
trying to talk all deep and [ __ ] after
like a battle and they're like just
killed a guy and he's like i can't
always make my own dharma bro
he's like doing this whole thing and
then it's just the guy next to him is
like man i hate these [ __ ]
he's just like you know that's why i
love you man you're so messed up
it's just two totally different guys
and that was like dude that's how i
heard a lot of those boys talk
apparently the guy with the hat was a
sergeant
and don holloway doesn't work for black
rifle coffee is what they're saying
don dan whatever his name was dan was
one of the guys that was involved in the
founding of it
he's not he's no longer he might not
work for him but he was at the beginning
but he was there at the beginning
it happened in november i used to argue
with all my left friends that called
that called conservatives racist because
i thought they were just making this up
then i got but it turns out they were
right it turns out conservatives are
right it turns out that when i was a
conservative i wasn't aware of they were
racist on this side we didn't know we
were just living in our little bubble
then you're [ __ ]
if you didn't know that they were
[ __ ] by the way there's a bunch of
[ __ ] racists on the left too there's
[ __ ] racists exist but now i would
argue that there's no
first you that's a disingenuous argument
you would never hear mike and i ever
ever ever say that there's no race to
conservatives aren't racist
no
i'm sure there's [ __ ] plenty of
conservatives that are racist plenty
[ __ ] lefties and bernie bros that are
also racist sure in different ways but
everyone is this is this is this guy
being disingenuous
by that group of people and went it
opened my eyes of oh my god this exists
how do you live oh my god the success
that's like literally a thing how do you
live
in a world where donald trump got
elected because of 4chan and not know
that racism exists
how how is that possible i didn't know
it exists because they left me alone
because they thought i was an ally well
it's also it's also very small i thought
it was an ally first off no
conservatives use the word ally so let's
start with that you piece of [ __ ] it's
very small um and that's what evan was
referring to though and that's that
comment by the way also the comment like
it's very small no most people are
racist i mean we could lie to ourselves
and we could pretend like you know we're
[ __ ] we could lie to ourselves but
everyone's racist
he was like the customers that we lost i
would pay to leave because i don't want
them associated with me he was not
calling conservatives racist he was not
calling anybody that supported trump
racist he wasn't saying any we were
talking about hey we don't want no but
you were just calling all of the proud
boys racist which still isn't true it's
still a shitty thing that's not true
yeah even even the hispanic ones and the
black ones
yeah it's like look we weren't painting
everyone with a broad stroke we were
just doing it to one group of people oh
okay okay then
to associate with our brands that's
pretty [ __ ] cut and dry this is the
conversation uh so what do you think
about races um yeah i don't like that
races can go [ __ ] themselves dude
racists bro i don't [ __ ] dude if
you're trying to be racist around me bro
i'll [ __ ] dude please i will knock you
the [ __ ] out dude if i hear you being
racist bro let's see but like me and my
buddies we like to joke all the time
like i made a coffee company that
basically glorifies the past 20 years of
disastrous bloodthirsty and unproductive
foreign policy in which we have somehow
still like got rid of all of our world
war ii goodwill the world hates us now
we have [ __ ] our country is crumbling
from the inside out we've spent
trillions of dollars we could have spent
fixing the country blowing up brown
people
i've personally killed brown people
before but dude
i hear you making jokes about chinese
people bro bro i will knock you the [ __ ]
out dude
that's exactly the point and i would
even can i add one extra to that
these guys say the n word all the time
maybe not anymore no but they used to
yeah but they used to i'm sorry and i
know this this might be another
stereotype but let's be realistic here
nobody that has that much sports
memorabilia hasn't dropped the n-word
when their team lost a bet
you know
sorry that's not [ __ ] realistic and
nobody's going to sit here and
to peddle me these [ __ ] lies they
peddle these lies i [ __ ] hate racist
all right no you don't you [ __ ] you
don't hate racist when they were paying
your [ __ ] bills do you
yeah i like to shoot afghan i like to
protect pedophile afghani opium warlords
while i listen to five finger death
punch but brother so help me god if i
see you make jokes about black people
dude we're fist fighting and that's my
[ __ ] point everybody everybody is
[ __ ] racist and i really believe that
to my core in different ways everyone's
racist and it's a byproduct of tribalism
that's just the way it works that's it
but if you're gonna be like what they're
doing and they're saying like we're not
racist and then call all the proud boys
racist and you're a [ __ ] hypocrite
right
i mean either everyone's racist or
ev only every proud boy's racist
according to them mm-hmm
pretty [ __ ] cut and dry this is the
conversation uh so what do you think
about racist races
i don't like that races can go [ __ ]
themselves what are you saying i'm
racist
[ __ ] you christian and then and then
they twist this okay
i'm gonna let's do a little thing here i
i run i run black rifle coffee and for
some reason i decided to do something
with the new york times which is pretty
stupid to begin with but fine let's say
i do
ask marsh ask me what i think about
racist
so what do you think about like racists
i mean really honestly i think that word
has been overused a lot it really
depends on what you perceive to be
racist you know if you're talking about
calling somebody the n word and not
giving them a job yeah that's pretty
shitty you know you should probably
shouldn't do that kind of stuff but you
know i've read what the new york times
wrote and i think that you call anybody
racist that doesn't agree with your
policies
that's it
that's what you say
okay i just wrote that in my notes that
you are a
see you don't win no matter what you do
you don't
you don't win
stuff
the the reporter was in the art room
there is a bunch there is thousands 3
000 different designs you've seen gary's
office like it's a [ __ ] it's it's
it's a masterpiece of [ __ ] i'm sorry
yes so
there is a pile that says hold and on
top of that pile was the design that
evan had done
saint michael he's the same patron of
paratroopers
first
what
he's for can i explain
[ __ ] what
can i explain this for the love of god
do
so these were instinct that like
you know since they were paratroopers
that they're the only guys in the world
that
use
uh you know st michael the archangel
uh saint michael the archangel is the
patron saint of
any
warrior class in a christian society
like he's always been sort of the
the avatar for
literally like sword of god cutting the
devil's head off type of like that's the
image
of michael the archangel is
the you know basically like god's head
general warrior guy right so a lot of
these dudes use
saint michael as a thing i don't know
why they said the paint should say the
paratroopers because that sounds so
cringe but they do use like uh insignias
sometimes with the you know angel uh
archangel uh michael on them because
it's badass and if you are in a
christian rooted culture it is kind of
cool you know but my thing is
not because they're gonna get into why
they now they it's it's a whole this
thing's a whole mess but just actually
just play because i'm so mad that i i
can't make my points and i get you get
your plate sbr putting his foot on satan
the reporter goes why is that on hold
he's like wow we were told by by the
legal department that this was added to
the dod's banned extremist images he's
like so we're going to look into that
before we launch it that was the
conversation
why would we look into it before we
launch it because we don't want black
rifle coffee as a brand added to a band
yeah for somebody who's not part of the
company sure saying we a lot huh
item on the dod's list saying if they
came out and said you cannot display
black rifle coffee in a government
facility that affects our afes uh stuff
all the stores on bases like like that
is so detrimental to the business
no no you're absolutely right because
yeah soldiers aren't racist can i point
canal can i point out
so this is where they made like 10
mistakes
uh one
how about
not using um
an angel
as a marketing tool right would be maybe
the first thing i would do
yeah
but let's say i did use uh one of god's
angels to sell my shitty coffee right
um that's a really good [ __ ] point
once i was pressured by the government
to remove that i would probably triple
down
and go
you know what
i actually [ __ ] i [ __ ] dare you
i dare you to take us to court or we'll
take you to court i dare you to fight us
in court and call us white supremacists
because we used the archangel michael in
our marketing material so please let's
have that battle government you want to
fight it in court do you want to be
anti-christian in court do you want this
headache or do you want to just shut the
[ __ ] up and let us sell our goddamn
cause well amanda that seems like it
would have been easier way to go amanda
pointed something out uh st michael's
also the angel of low low prices
so that would have been cool
are you sure i'm not positive but at
this point mike anything's possible just
to think that they have a large
corporate ally somewhere like hey they
won't really say it but because they
printed team michael they're
turned into and this is where stupid
people stupid i will call stupid guys
we're stupid you could call us stupid
guy who thought it was cool to do a
drinking bro shirt that looks like porno
man oh bro that's so cool pornhub
remember you know pornography
you know what dude i don't come in here
and infringe on your gimmick i don't go
out there and shoot iraqi children in
the face i don't appreciate you
expressing disdain and looking down on
your audience okay you have your thing i
have my thing stay in your lane drinking
bros
stupid if you were part of this
that that a
evan was the deciding person that said
st michael was racist no i jumped with a
saint michael pennant evan jumped with
saint michael penned matt had had a
saint michael pena all of us were fans
oh so you had a symbol that meant
something to you but you have zero
convictions and you colla and you caved
the moment it was going to affect your
bottom line not even affect your bottom
line might affect your body possibly you
caved immediately wow how admirable of
you you know now when you tell the story
that way i guess i'm on your side
why he was creating the art we were just
told hey this was added to a dod banned
list okay well let's look into it and
then also let's look at another argument
if it's five people doing it then we'll
publish the thing but if it's like ten
thousand [ __ ] that started some
militia group in the woods that hate
black people then we're not going to
publish that [ __ ] that but
but there is not 10 000 people in the
woods starting a militia group no no no
but when you served there was uh 10 000
people in the middle east that hated
[ __ ] brown people
right yeah if there's one thing these
[ __ ] former army guys and marines if
there's one thing they hate it's
militias being formed by the people who
live in those areas to defend their
[ __ ] ancestral lands they don't like
that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] why would you don't be cool
dude if we had like a revenge of the sis
logo
but it looked like the [ __ ] bang bros
dude
bro so everybody knows like
how manly we are yeah yo we should also
get like uh
uh uh like something about like
something about like bacon
oh bacon you know what mike i'm looking
actually here and our marketing team has
a marketing research team has said men
like bacon
how about this how about this we do like
some cool shots like just like black
rifle did what we do is we get some big
titties in bikinis american flag bikinis
i love this and they'll be shooting
ar-15s except hear me out on this we
have to add all of the effects in post
because nobody would ever ask bikini
models to fire a live firearm with a
bikini on because of all the ejected
brass so we could totally lie and make
it seem like the chicks are shooting
guns but they're not really shooting
guns let's just lie all the time like
black rifle does
nice
they never see those commercials where
they do that like but they have two
chicks
in these like fishing line tiny bikinis
and they're shooting guns and they're
like chicka and you're like that's not
you would never ask somebody in a bikini
to fire a rifle
so uh no eye protection on no nothing
so this i'm gonna try i have a little
isolated clip here of the alex jones
thing
so uh check this out check out how cool
these guys are you ready here we go he
was like the customers that we lost i
would pay to leave because i don't want
them associated with me our opinion on
the customers that we lost the racist
weirdos that we don't care about that we
want nothing to do with because you're a
hater little bit that's an in-cell
living in your own basement you've not
achieved
your mind bingo bingo bingo no no no no
bingo bingo bingo you got 80. you got it
i got bingo
the your mom's basement is their
favorite insult for anyone that's not as
cool as them see man because you're a
[ __ ] you you don't hear these guys
you're a [ __ ] civilian
he actually does say that at the end
he's like you've never served oh okay
all right so since i didn't go [ __ ]
since i didn't go like go off and drop
white phosphorus on syrian children i
guess i just can't uh i guess i'm not
allowed to have an opinion
in your life and half of the [ __ ] that
alex jones down the road here and by the
way i'm gonna publish his dress soon
he's going to and you heard that
correctly
he will be that fat [ __ ] alex jones
he will be publishing
his address soon now if we said that
royce about anyone
what do you think would happen to our
now forget about a strike for a minute
what do you think would happen to our
entire
youtube channel gone immediately there
would there wouldn't even be a wouldn't
it even be a [ __ ]
there wouldn't be strikes
there would be nothing right you we
would get the email that says due to
multiple violations your account has
been terminated
now i have a question for you
when the drinking bros were on alex
jones or when he was on their show
that was fine right well no no yeah what
can i explain to you royce royce is so
bad at this i'm stupid i'm stupid let me
explain well because the guy said you're
stupid he was talking to you he wasn't
talking to me because i get it i'm you
know
um
so the way this works is royce c they
needed him then
to sell their shitty coffee to a bunch
of
boomers
and now they don't need him because they
have the new york times and they
probably have some distribution deals
that were
timed right around the new york times
see they don't they don't need us
anymore guys
so when they were when the drinking bros
were hanging out when the drinking bros
were hanging out with alex jones in 2019
right when they were [ __ ] hanging out
and he was plugging their coffee and
saying it was great that was fine but
now fat [ __ ] alex jones needs to be
doxxed because he doesn't agree with
them with what they're talking about the
new york times that's you're being
unfair royce they're going to dox him
because they don't agree with a man
because he didn't serve
oh you're right come on man
no no somebody says alex jones had them
on infowars no no it's better than that
it's not that alex jones had him on
infowars alex jones let them do his
their podcast in the infowars studio
jesus alex jones let them do
their podcast in the infowars studio but
that was fine even here's the thing this
is what bothers me
alex jones you might not lie you might
like him he might not like him right
that's your prerogative but alex jones
has been alex jones since
since his [ __ ] public broadcasting
days alex jones has always been very
consistent right
alex jones has been a consistent dude
he's always [ __ ] been a consistent
dude
these guys the moment that alex jones
goes and these black raffle coffee guys
you know why they're talking new york
times
that's all it takes for them to
[ __ ]
try and dox him
the moment you don't [ __ ] play ball
with these by the way you're in the
military that doesn't make you special
that makes you a [ __ ] high school
dropout and look no [ __ ] offense to
people that served i know
i understand some of your good people
and i get it but this era superiority
that by the way because of people like
alex jones and because of a lot of
people on the right that we have
instilled in military people to make
them think that they are better than you
yeah we've over empowered them yeah this
needs to stop
like it should be a respected thing
to a certain extent maybe not nowadays
because what we do is atrocious but
there was a time when i am okay with
having a certain level of default
respect for somebody in uniform who
served in the military and you're like
okay like i'm not one of those cringe
guys that goes thank you for your [ __ ]
like that kind of [ __ ] is just
ridiculous but like
i can understand like when you see a guy
like i'll be more a little more polite
to a guy like if a guy's in his [ __ ]
fatigues and he's getting on a plane or
something i'll be like oh yeah yeah you
go ahead you go first or whatever like
turns out that that was just you know
turns out that was just a no limit
soldier
it really he's flying out of atlanta oh
that makes sense now [ __ ] you idiot and
then you let him in and then his entire
entourage walks in front of you too
you're like wait a minute i thought that
guy was a marine turns out it was
mystico
but you know what i respect mr gilmore
yeah i know you're right absolutely
because he got because it's more
dangerous to serve in the no limit no
limit army in atlanta than it does the
[ __ ] servant over here he made the
song shake your ass watch yourself and
you know what he probably killed less
people than the drinking bros yeah and
by the way black rifle coffee semper is
right they're not trying to open little
stand-alone locations
uh like you know businesses like
starbucks and they don't want to be
taken down they went from being the
conservative coffee group that doesn't
give a [ __ ] to now just being the hey
man sports guys am i right sports but
it's not going to work now because
you've your optics are still
geared towards
conservative tropes
but you're pandering to the left so this
is going to fail for them i mean i don't
think like it's not they're not going to
go out of business but no no of course
not this hasn't been a good strategy
they make really good commercials like
the one i posted in shelby oh we'll
check out their commercial and you know
while i do that i just want to remind
them that alex jones selling his bone
broth is going to make more money than
any of your [ __ ] coffee just keep
that in mind black rifle
uh let's see here
this is a commercial hello everyone we
have a new person joining us tonight yep
hold on a second hold on a second mike
you didn't catch this because you're not
a martial everyone we have you're not a
marketing genius like they are merch so
you didn't catch this oh tits now he
caught it it takes next tank a little
bit
tit cell
baby
looks like arya stark got a boob job
and you know what the best part is is
that they're going to what are you
talking about maisie williams has giant
tits
oh okay they're giant apparently you
fought and i do
huh guess you follow her boobs more than
i do
um
but i i do like that now they're they're
going into this world of virtue
signaling
they're not going to be able to go back
so now it's like now you've cocked on
the race thing and you've cucked on your
marketing materials you're threatening
all these people that used to support
you you're just cucking cocking cucking
and now
it's never going to be good enough
they're going to learn that hustle
they're going to learn that now it's
going to be like you know these black
rifle guys it's kind of problematic
like the way they objectify women you
know it's kind of problematic the way
they object they're going to have
everybody on their ass now because now
everybody knows you're weak
so let me get this straight
what would be the point of doxing alex
jones because the only point would be
for people to go bother him at his home
where you know that there would be no
other reason right
yeah of course yeah
new person joining us tonight um hi i'm
matt matt why don't you uh i don't know
tell us a little bit about yourself um i
i guess it's like kind of hard to admit
but i mean oh this is the mat that has
nothing to do with black rifle coffee
he's just a drinking bros guy yeah being
ass
tactical
oh [ __ ] bro
[ __ ] guns dude
oh yeah i just realized that too that's
the other thing they're gonna have to
deal with
they're fetishizing guns
they're fetishizing women's tits like so
this new
mainstream woke crowd that they're gonna
try to pander to they're going to come
after them
for every little thing now oh yeah
oh yeah
and they're going to be like wow uh
instruments of death
they're literally fetishizing assault
rifles that children get shot in schools
with
now you're gonna have no allies since
you like using that word
that's actually the one plus side by the
way to covid i actually don't want the
schools to ever open back up because
think about it that helps us keep our
guns can't have there's no schools fair
enough
yeah we all have our vices i've been
trying to buy f-15s and nuclear warheads
i'm masturbating oh [ __ ] bad badass
let's give me boners i jerk off
demolition ranch videos
see they're court they're funny dude
[ __ ] based
[ __ ] based why is vaush in this fight
at this point it might as well right
videos
you jerk off to matt carr i [ __ ] love
israel all right man relax okay
caleb why don't you share your success
story what's up i'm caleb uh
i haven't operated in 10 years i have
gauged ears
not one ounce of carbon on these hands
i'm actually a lot cooler than everybody
here
actually got a coin
for being cool
why is a um
coffee company doing skits
because man gorilla marketing bro
i don't know
[Music]
well this is so badass you're not
listening to the cool rock guitar
huh
it's so
bad ass bro
i think these guys are pretty cool
yeah they're they're really they're
really cool i think owning black rifle
coffee is kind of neat
you just don't understand football marsh
you just don't understand coffee much